salons are gone
what
gone all of them yep
what about the vending machines
gone jesus
uh don't tell me laser tag fed's found
it all so
hey guys pete here last week i was left
wondering would gene be able to have
another taste of the scamming life and
then walk away from it even though that
didn't seem likely it was possible
because there was a good chance we'd be
revisiting the breaking bad timeline to
learn where the return of brian cranston
and aaron paul would fit in jimmy mcgill
first appeared in their series in an
episode titled better call saul so it's
fitting they would show up in episode 11
which is titled breaking bad i would say
that their appearance lived up to the
hype they managed to include them in a
way that was more about jimmy it was
fantastic to revisit that space and to
see these two great actors play off each
other one more time but after the dust
settled i was left with a careful what
you wish for feeling not in that it
wasn't an enjoyable episode because it
was great but in the sense that there
were so many payoffs i'd been waiting
for that all sort of put a darker spin
on things for instance i wanted to see
more scenes with mike he did have a
perfect ending in the better call saul
timeline with papa varga in episode 9
but it's mike so please find a way to
bring him back as long as it's in
service of saul's story anyway your 12
30 just walked in and boom more mike and
as a bonus it's during his sunglasses
phase did i want his reappearance to be
him giving saul solid advice to avoid
walter white only to have him completely
disregard it not exactly and we'll come
back to the implications of that in a
bit another thing i've been dying to
know about since way back in season 4
was the phone call that saul asked
francesca to answer on his birthday did
i want that to be him calling to check
on how things are in albuquerque in a
word no i definitely did want this to
mean that kim was still alive and for
them to have a chance to get back in
touch with each other but not in the way
that it played out there was a lot of
important information in this
conversation that i should mention
though things did not cool off after
walter white died francesca is still
being watched and since skyler white got
her deal that only leaves saul and jesse
for the authorities to go after skyler
getting a deal would indicate that the
lottery ticket with the gps coordinates
that walt gave her led them to discover
hank and gomi's bodies francesca hearing
that jesse's car was found near the
border means that skinny pete's plan to
have badger ditch his car near the
border and el camino worked we also get
updates on some of the characters saul
surrounded himself with she doesn't know
what happened to kooby danny aka price
or ira but i'm happy to say that hill
finally made it out of that safe house
because the dea held him there under
false pretenses he walked and is
presumably back home in louisiana ada
bill oakley left the courthouse vending
machines behind and became a defense
attorney and seeing his sole s bus bench
advertisements was a great way to
explain visually that we were back in
albuquerque and some time had passed the
call turns out to be a wonderful
send-off for francesca that has made all
the better by her hanging up before jean
says i guess this is goodbye and the
last big piece of information is that
the only person who called her after it
all went down was kim she asked if jimmy
was still alive and he interprets this
as you mean there's a chance she might
want to get back together because he has
his u-turn moment when he gets to a
crossroads and decides to go back to
call her apparently he knows where she
works or at least thinks he does and
just as he makes the call and asks for
her we're cut out of the conversation
from what we watch from across the
street it feels safe to say that making
the call was a bad idea but we'll have
to wait to find out why that was
we do see his rageful reaction that
involves smashing the receiver and
kicking in the glass for good measure
because this is so extreme i think it
only makes sense that he did talk to her
and as frustrating as it is not to know
what was said the effect it has on him
is what really matters after kim left we
found out that he became saul as a way
to cope with everything that happened we
know jimmy never dealt with chuck's or
howard's deaths and that he tries to
forget about what happened with kim by
throwing himself into being the criminal
lawyer saul goodman after episode 609
that put a sad spin on the character's
existence during breaking bad but this
episode makes things more complicated i
already mentioned him ignoring mike's
warning about walt and what that brought
to mind was the switch in his office in
the first episode of season 2. that made
the point that when he gets something in
his mind he can't help himself and they
jump back and forth between the two
timelines to really drive this idea home
in omaha he's reeling from whatever kim
told him on the phone and so he heads
back to jeff's where he shows marion how
to watch funny cat videos on her new
laptop i thought the way odenkirk played
gene here was really telling he's
laughing with her one minute but gets
deadly serious when he tells jeff they
should take their drinks outside he
needs to throw himself into this as fast
as possible to drown out his thoughts of
kim the scams start off feeling fun in
the same way that nippy was he appears
to pick marks that aren't nice people
and especially the first one feels like
he might even have it coming to him he
uses the name victor with a k and it
feels like he might be chasing some of
what he got out of those early scams
with gisele we see that he has things
planned out he has jeff take the night
shift and obtain some barbiturates gene
finds guys he can befriend at bars while
pretending to get drunk with them and
then have jeff drug them with
complimentary water on the way home he
uses a piece of tape to leave their
doors unlocked so that buddy can come in
behind him and steal their identities
while they're knocked out they sell
their information for a decent payday
and then do it all again in albuquerque
it's been a few years since kim left so
at this point he's just chasing a bigger
high after his post kidnap conversation
where he put it together that walter is
heisenberg he sees an opportunity i
suppose that some people might look at
this as saul being responsible for who
walter white will become but i think
that is missing the point of who
heisenberg was we have two stories about
two different journeys so i look at this
as it being what happens when they come
together and i've always thought of
their transformations as being unique to
each other but at least at the end of
this episode they're looking a lot more
similar because things do get dark
quickly in omaha as gene starts to
resemble saul a lot more than jimmy he
was already wearing the pinky ring and
he adds a bluetooth headset and the back
massager and he starts sleeping with sex
workers again there's a moment when he
realizes that one of his marks has
cancer where you think he might pump on
the brakes but it goes in the opposite
direction he gets a call and rushes over
to jeff's because buddy couldn't go
through with his part of the robbery he
noticed that their mark took the same
cancer meds his dad was taking and
decides not to steal from him gene flips
out and tries to convince him that he'll
get over it and when that doesn't work
he decides to do it himself
there's a great shot on the way to the
house with jeff looking at gene in his
rear view mirror where you can see that
he's really afraid of him at this point
it's a complete 180 from when he was
first in his cab and it underlines how
quickly and completely that gene went
off the rails everything about this
decision to go to the house is
compulsive it's been long enough that
the barbiturates may no longer be
working buddy removed the tape so he
won't be able to walk right in and when
he breaks the window that undermines the
entire purpose of the scam they were
going to great lengths to make sure
these guys wouldn't realize they'd been
robbed and as the episode comes to an
end we know that won't be the case this
time and as they've done throughout the
episode they cut back and forth between
the two timelines and there's a great
parallel of him walking into walt's high
school here with what gene does at the
end of this episode the decision to go
to walt and to tell him he has the right
product but not the right connections
and strategy and then offer to provide
him those things it was the beginning of
the end for saul goodman it makes this
final decision to go after this other
cancer man feel like it could be the end
of gene so careful what you wish for
this episode gave us answers and the
return of walt and jesse but it made the
jimmy's side winning the battle for his
soul feel less likely they were almost
hitting us over the head with the
similarities between the fall assault
goodman and the end of gene takabic in
both of those situations he was making
decisions and chasing after what he was
wishing for and we know what that's
about now and at least in the breaking
bad timeline we know how that worked out
i really liked how they managed the
jumping back and forth and the
transition of the grave in the desert to
him awakened the bed he made for himself
in omaha really sticks with you there's
an incredible amount of references like
the gas station where francesca gets the
call is the same one where jesse gave
the girl to counter meth and speaking of
that the whole find the rock shaped like
new jersey and follow the fishing line
to the drainpipe was fun to watch i
don't know if i needed the answer to
what happened to huel but i was happy
when i got it and i read in the
hollywood reporter that thomas now said
that he named price daniel because he
was hoping to make him the danny from
the laser tag and they never got around
to it so he was excited to slip that in
during the call and make it official i
also saw several posts that pointed out
that he was pictured on one of the
driver's licenses during the montage as
we become used to with this show and i
would say in his episodes in particular
it was a heavy episode with just the
right amount of funny moments included
to balance things out there were so many
things in the crystal ship you had him
asking if oakley came out the massage
machine itself and mike's reaction to it
francesca as a landlord marian with
funny cat videos and i'm not sure if it
was supposed to be funny but i did find
buddy's incredibly well-behaved dog to
be a nice touch it's not like this is a
surprise but i have to mention the
performances watching odenkirk play saul
and possibly showing us a new sided gene
after the phone call it's wild how each
one of these different versions of jimmy
comes across cranston and paul with the
aid of some beanies seem to slip right
back into their roles i think if i had
to choose a favorite moment it would be
jesse saying dick under his breath but
walt's lecture about how they just need
to let it cool down is right up there
with it the last thing i got that i
really wanted was to see gene and kim
reconnect and i would have never guessed
that it could lead to him putting
himself on this path because we didn't
hear what they said and because we don't
know what she's up to i feel pretty
confident that we're gonna see this same
conversation from her side in the next
episode she is working at a store that
sells sprinklers and it's titled
waterworks based on the timing it's
possible she just learned what he was up
to with walt it stands out though that
he thought he knew where she worked he
was able to call the operator and get in
touch with her just like that it's hard
to say where we go in the timeline from
here it doesn't necessarily feel like we
need to revisit anything with walt and
jesse although i wouldn't mind it but
him having this information makes it
seem like it's at least possible that
they got together at least once during
the breaking bad timeline what they said
and whether that happened or if he just
had someone go find her all of that
being a mystery means that we really
have no idea how she'd be feeling about
him as far as the way things were left
after episode 609 it's safe to say that
she still cares about him she doesn't
believe that they can be together but
she wouldn't want him to be suffering
either considering she knows what he's
been through and she knows him better
than anyone else she may understand what
he's doing with this saul goodman
persona at the very least she
understands that him burying all these
unresolved feelings about chuck about
howard that none of that's good for him
but without knowing what she's facing in
her own life it's hard to imagine how
those two things will influence each
other if there's any chance that he
turns things around because at the end
of this episode he looks set up to go
down in a blaze of glory similar to mr
walter white i never envisioned that as
an ending for him so i'm interested to
see if there's a way that he can resolve
that if he can move past that and
there's still two more full episodes to
go to see if he does and i think that is
a great place to leave things let me
know in the comments what you thought
about the episode i think tom sniles
went out on a high note i wouldn't say
that this episode topped bad choice road
or planet execution but i think that's
more about where they fell in the story
and what was going on then about
anything he did in this particular
episode next week we're gonna see the
last episode directed by vince gilligan
and then one more that's written and
directed by the showrunner peter gold so
let me know what you hope to see happen
how you think it might end and what you
definitely don't want to see please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon
you